as social animals our success our
happiness our joy our ability to get
anything done requires help the human
brain cannot comprehend the negative it
is incapable not everyone who owns a
small business as an entrepreneur there
are small business owners and they're
entrepreneurs need motivation to believe
nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being a law student who ended up
working in marketing launching his own
business and being a highly sought after
speaker and author he's simon Sinek and
here's my take on his top ten rules a
success volume for all so if you want to
know what simon and others have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself even though I'm gonna sell you
the most beautiful hammer I'm not gonna
guarantee the instructional integrity of
the house
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one live your life on purpose I was
living in London and attending law
school I was becoming disillusioned with
the law I happen to be dating a girl who
was in advertising she said you might
like advertising and boom I have a
career in marketing like I fell into it
so many of us fall into our careers and
fall into our jobs and even if we do
pursue something we want to do
sometimes it takes diversions right this
is this is what I mean by living our
lives by accident which is we largely
leave the direction of our careers and
sometimes even our own happiness to
others our bosses you know all of that
thing so what it means to live your life
on purpose means you understand the
direction you're heading but you remain
agnostic as to the route most people try
very very hard to plan the route in
other words what's your plan people say
well first I'm gonna work here for three
years then I'm gonna quit and I'm gonna
do this and then for four years and I
got the route plan and the question is
where are you going right and that to me
is what it means to have purpose it
means to have destination right it's
like waking up in the morning and saying
I'm going on holiday so this is where
you going said I'm going on vacation I
told you you're like where are you going
vacation right and how are you gonna get
there like well I'm taking route 95 so
you've got the route planned but you
have no destination and you see this in
companies all the time you know why does
your company exist growth great why are
you growing why do you need to grow what
is growth mean because we're company we
have to grow and so they figure out all
of these paths for growth but they don't
know where they're going
I would rather someone wake up in the
morning and say California I'm trying to
get into California and I don't care
what route I take I'm gonna start down
Route 95 and if I find a better route
I'm gonna take it if there's traffic on
Route 95 I'm gonna take a side road so
this is what happened in my career
people kept telling me that I was
unfocused because I kept taking side
roads I wasn't unfocused I was going
around obstacles so that's what it means
to live a life of purpose it means I
live every single day of my life trying
to get to an end point in my case to
create a world in which the vast
majority of people
wake up every single morning inspired to
go to work feel safe when they're there
and return home at the end of the day
fulfilled by the work that they do that
is the destination I'm trying to reach I
don't know how I'm gonna get there but
I'm gonna try every path I can to get
there highly highly focused that's what
it means to live a life on purpose
we're often given this advice like do
what you love yeah like what am I
supposed to do it yes like let's find
your passion like thank you like great
what like I don't know what to do
tomorrow for me passion is the result of
something right so if you work hard for
something you don't believe in that's
called stress and if you work for some
heart or something you do believe in
that's called passion so it's finding
the belief it's finding the cause it's
finding the purpose and the passion then
shows up so it's not about doing
something with passion and then finding
the cause it's finding the cause
starting with why and then the passion
is what is what results rule number two
be a courageous leader number two it's
embarrassing this has to be on the list
courageous leadership courageous leaders
are the ones who are willing to
sacrifice the short term in order to
advance the long term courageous leaders
are the ones who willing to say no to
the money because it's coming from a
dirty source and rather say yes even
though they know they'll have to tighten
the belt in the short term because it's
the right thing to do having a Just
Cause if we don't actually follow the
just cause we don't actually make
decisions through the lens of the just
cause is just marketing it's just
marketing I'll give you my favorite
example right
the IOC the International Olympic
Committee they have a mission statement
what they believe is their Just Cause
which is to inva advance the world make
the world a better place through sport
but for the fact that they're all
corrupt it's a great idea my point is is
you actually have to have leadership
that desperately profoundly believes in
the cause and will make decisions to
advance that cause they would sooner
sacrifice their own personal interests
to take care of their people they would
never sacrifice their people to protect
their own interests it's called
leadership
it's called leadership we confuse rank
and leadership rank has nothing to do
with leadership I know many people who
sit at the highest levels of
organization
who are not leaders they have authority
and we do is they tell us because they
have authority over us but we would not
follow them and yet I know many people
who sit at lower ranks who have no
authority and yet they have made a
choice the choice to look after the
person to the left of them and the
choice to look after the person to the
right of them and we would trust them
and follow them anywhere leadership is
the acceptance of the awesome
responsibility to create an environment
in which people can work at their
natural best rule number three
talk about your beliefs I went to see a
play with a friend of mine who is an
actor and the play was awful I mean a
train wreck the script was awful the
directing was awful I mean it was an
absolute train wreck the question you
asked was about collaboration right
should any of those actors have taken
the part now of course if you're gonna
take a part because you need an extra
cash a little extra cash or you want to
get a Lex tractus then you have to do so
I think knowing I'm doing this for the
money or I'm doing this just to keep
keep my skills sharp but I'm under no
illusion that this is something that I
connect with but I'm gonna do the best
that I can and then don't lie to
yourself you know the other problem is
don't do that too often because that'll
just destroy any passion that you have
for your medium right and I think and
we've talked about this which is which
is any artist any person but especially
artists have to know their y-you have to
know why you're showing up in the first
place and you have to be able to talk
about it because if you talk about it
things happen people go I like you right
now you may not get the part but you're
more likely to find people who want to
work with you even if you're not the
most talented one who auditioned this is
my career by the way right when I
learned to talk about what I believed I
didn't talk about the things I've done I
didn't talk about the parts I've had or
the shows I've been in or who trained me
where the schools I went to resume
resume resume I started I learn
to talk about what I believed and some
people thought it was cheesy they didn't
call me back good and some people went
that's great and I was not the most
talented not the most experienced not
the best at my field but because they
stood for or believed in what I stood
for they wanted to work with me they
would rather work with someone who
understood them who got them more than
somebody who would just take orders and
do exactly what they wanted regardless
of facility rule number four get help
there's a paradox being a human being
unfortunately at all times every moment
of every day we are both individuals and
members of groups right we are both
responsible for ourselves and our
happiness and our joy but at the same
time we're members of families or
members of churches or members of teams
were members of companies like we're
members of multiple groups every single
day at every moment and this produces
some complications we have to make
decisions so do we put our self first
or do we put the group first and there's
a debate some people say oh you have to
take care of yourself before you can
take care of the group and some say no
no you take care of the group and that's
what helps they will take care of you
and the answer is yes it's not one or
the other it's actually both
simultaneously it is a challenge but at
the end of the day there's no getting
around it as social animals our success
our happiness our joy our ability to get
anything done requires help and those
who embrace the fact that they cannot do
everything alone that they need the
support and love and it doesn't mean
somebody who's physically helping you
live something sometimes it might be
someone who just believes in you these
things are essential and there's just no
getting around it rule number five have
a worthy rival the next part is a worthy
rival now I said before that the only
true competitor in an infinite game is
yourself this is true what your
competition does is it helps reveal to
you your weaknesses admire the others in
your organization not to beat them
there's no such thing not to be number
one there's no such thing but if
somebody else is better than you at
something that means you have to go work
harder yourself it's
running in a race if you're driven to be
number one if you're driven to make the
most money if you're driven to show up
in at some arbitrary ranking that you
didn't even have a say in that's like
tripping the the next runner you will
win the race but you're still a slow
runner rather fall behind this year and
then you work and work and work because
ultimately the goal is not to be number
one this year the goal is to create an
organization that will outlast every
single one of you this is about building
strong foundations this is about looking
long term and the short term money is
simply fuel to to to make the car go we
don't own cars to buy more fuel we own
cars to go somewhere it's the same thing
in an organization your organization
exists to advance something the money is
simply there to make it go and I fear
that what has happened in the university
system is similar to what I'm seeing in
business it's similar to what I'm seeing
in politics it's similar to what I'm
seeing in hospitals which is an over the
sense of excessive pressure to bring
money in at the expense of something
else
there's an excessive amount of
short-termism
and massive amounts of rationalizing
this is just the game we just have to do
it if we don't somebody else will the
obsession with getting grants meaning
you're hiring people who are more likely
to help you get a grant even though
they're teaching things that we don't
necessarily even need or want
that's called short-termism rule number
six focus on the positive thinking these
people will always complain that why
can't I ever get that and these people
complain I can never get a job you're
gonna be stressed no matter what focus
on the thing that you're getting because
that's the choice you made right I draw
much rather you focus the thing you you
you or you were pursuing rather the
thing you're missing and so this idea of
affirmative thinking positive thinking
is essential for all people but I think
it's especially essential for artists
and there's a very very simple
biological reason for it which is the
human brain
cannot comprehend the negative it is
incapable yes it's true I'll give you an
example okay
no no I'll give you an example you don't
have to believe me I'll prove it I'll
prove it
okay the human brain cannot comprehend
the negative you're ready don't think of
an elephant
you can't you can't tell the human brain
not to do something right and so what
happens is we very often reinforce
things when we put things in the
negative right I can't get apart I can't
get apart I can't get apart right or I
can't do this versus I'm gonna keep
doing this I'm gonna keep doing this I'm
gonna keep doing this right and and it's
such a huge thing to convert things into
the affirmative you're supposed to do
with children as well we're supposed to
say instead of saying to children don't
eat on the couch we're supposed to say
eat at the table right we tell people
what we want them to do not what them
what we don't want to do pilots know
this right it is well known in the pilot
community that when you tell a pilot
don't hit the obstacle they'll hit the
obstacle because what they're doing is
focusing on the obstacle rule number
seven do something I went to this event
and just by sheer coincidence at the
dinner I'm sitting next to dawn and Sam
gold worm who run this company called
1229 and that's exactly what they do
dawn is a master knows who used to work
for Cody the perfume company so you
should produce all the famous perfumes
that we all know and they want us to
start their own company where they
design custom cents for brands but the
way to think about this is beyond some
of verbena and patchouli the way don't
explain that to me is there are seven
notes on the musical scale and you can
play chopsticks or you can play a
Beethoven symphony it's the same seven
notes that's what you do with it and she
does the same thing with smell which is
you can have simple smells or you can
have highly complex ornate orchestras a
symphony it's rather and so they sat
down with me and took me through a
fantastic process and they produced the
smell of optimism and it's the most
beautiful thing and the idea was born
out of the fact that I'm sitting next
onto this event and I
and said have you ever scented a book as
I never been done before and they said
no it's never been done I said well we
should really do that and so of course
my publisher was not excited to hear
about that but but it's the first time
that I know that a book has ever been
scented in this way so it is a scented
book the smell of optimism is what you
start with and it sets you on your
journey to enjoy the rest of the book
rule number eight have a just cause I'll
ask you a very simple question why does
your organization exist we don't need
you
clearly there's plenty of competition
clearly people have plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do a reasonably
good job they might even be better than
you in some areas so why do you exist
providing education is table stakes
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that that's why the industry exists
not why your organization exists that's
like when I talk to health care
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you but I know that the culture of
one organization is different than the
culture of another organization there
are cultural norms that wrap around the
sense of purpose cause or belief great
organizations understand they're just
cause they caused so just that people
would be willing to sacrifice to see the
advancement of that cause sacrifice
comes in many forms it meat might mean
working longer hours giving you my best
ideas turning down a better job that
offers me more money to stay here
because I believe in what you're doing
and I want to see that at versed one of
my favorite examples of a Just Cause is
the Declaration of Independence our
founding fathers declared literally
wrote down they declared why we needed
our own country all men are created
equal endowed with these unalienable
rights amongst which include life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
they were never against Britain the
whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
Britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
one independence there are always finite
games within the infinite game though
they won independence that didn't mean
that they had now provided all men are
equal now the real heavy lifting began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white Protestant men let's be
crystal clear but even early on during
the Revolutionary War George Washington
understood how limiting that was and he
realized that they had to have a broader
definition so he included Catholics he
banned any organizing against Catholics
and his armies and he would regularly
attend Mass to send the right message
sometime later we abolish slavery and
the 14th amendment sometime later we had
women's suffrage sometime later we had
Civil Rights Act sometime later we
implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving to provide this
thing called all men are equal people
are equal and though we will never
actually get there we will die trying
and the obstacles may always be
different and what a Just Cause is it is
a vision of the future that does not yet
exist and you will commit all of your
energies to advance that vision of the
world that you have and the people you
want to attract both those who work
there those who teach there and both
those who come to learn there believe in
your vision of the future so much so
that they may turn down a better offer
of cents from someone else because they
want to be around people who are
committed to building this world that
does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you run and represent can have different
visions or overlapping visions of the
world but you must be clear what your
Just Cause is what you stand for
otherwise the only thing I have to judge
you on is superficial things it's like
dating right it's like dating if if
somebody tells me what they stand for
who they are they talking about their
character and those are the people we
want to spend the rest of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are what they stand for with their
purpose what their cause what their
Leafs are what their values are the only
thing we have to judge them on is how
much money they make and how
good-looking they are rule number nine
stand out from others I'm a huge modern
dance lover like that's the thing I love
and I don't go to the Joyce anymore
because everything that they have on
their stage is good it's good everything
is safe to me they put things on their
stage that that's good they sell tickets
nothing's bad and nothing's great it's
all good I don't go anymore
I go to BAM a lot I have seen things
that have profoundly changed my view of
the world and I have walked out of more
things at BAM
literally I'm like I'm done and my
friends like you've got like we can I
have walked outs out of so many things
at Bam and yet I continued to go and
continue to go and I continue to go
because I know what they stand for
that's my preference I'm not saying it's
right or wrong I'm saying that's my
preference that I would rather take the
risk of walking out knowing that I might
get moved in a way that I've never
experienced before more than just go and
have a nice night out and see something
that I know is good right and I think
that goes for our careers as well you
know which is if you choose to be the
kind of artist that stands for something
that you want to be yourself and bring
yourself into everything that you do you
will get fewer parts you will the parts
you get will move you in a way that most
artists will not get moved or you can
bend and manipulate yourself a little
bit and sort of be a little bit more of
what they want and play their role and
even though you don't really buy into it
it's a part and I want to be an actor I
want to be a performer I'm gonna I'm
gonna do what they want you will
absolutely get more parts without a
doubt you will met you will can arguably
have a better career but will you'll be
profoundly moved as an artist the odds
are lower it's not I can't say never
it's just the odds are lower it's not
bad
or worse it is simply the decision on
how you choose to manage or lead your
own career both are acceptable right one
means you get to use your facility a lot
one means you get to work a lot one
means you might be able to do only your
art and actually make a living one means
that you're gonna be meeting a lot of
people and the odds are that you will
connect with somebody at some point or
you choose this route which is much more
difficult and is fraught with much more
risk and much more struggle but you
become known for the thing that you are
and rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip is be a
problem solver I think the word
entrepreneur is bandied about too
loosely mmm that not everyone who owns a
small business as an entrepreneur there
are small business owners and they're
entrepreneurs what's no interpreter and
you can find entrepreneurs in big
companies it doesn't means that there's
small business owners right I think
entrepreneurs are problem solvers I
think rather than risk takers yeah I
think fundamentally there are plenty of
risk takers I think who aren't
entrepreneur there's a risk taker of
your small business owner right you went
out to start the business but they're
not the same
I don't think and entrepreneurs are
those ones who they're constantly
looking to solve problems and that's
where I think they perceive opportunity
or the mischief that you describe I
don't think it's I don't think
inherently it's a sense of mischief
they're not trying to stir the pot for
the sake of stirring the pot I think
that they see something and they're like
we can make that better or we can fill
that hole and that's very much the way
the famous entrepreneurs the Elon Musk's
and the Richard Branson's operate they
see gaps they see things that don't work
as their jobs as did jobs they see
things that could be better or they I
mean Elon Musk was just interviewed by
Chris Anderson at Ted last week and
Chris Anderson and sort of near the end
of the interview it's online go watch it
it's really great Chris Anderson asks
Elon Musk's something to the effect of
why are you doing all these things like
why do you just stick with Tesla and be
done with it
like why do all the other stuff and you
look at and musk
you can see this look on his face and he
takes a long time to answer he actually
doesn't understand the question he
cannot understand why you wouldn't do
that and he sort of gets him fatik which
meal and musk is pretty amazing because
he doesn't get him Phatak but that's
basically what it is he gets some Phatak
and says because I want to live in a
world that's better than this two words
to that effect you know where I'm not
where the world that we're living right
now makes us unhappy why don't we want
to live in a world that makes us happy
you know he gets sort of he kind
understand and again
it's vision first and that's why he
doesn't understand why you wouldn't try
and solve problem
I've got a really special bonus clip
from Simon on how to become
the-best-version-of-yourself that I
think you're going to really enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
in your business and if you're feeling
bold leave the answers in the comments
below here we go question number one
what problem are you solving number two
what do you do to stay thinking positive
and number three who is your worthy
rival
there's no such thing as winning
business there's no such thing as
winning global politics and there's
definitely no such thing as winning
education but if we listen to the
language of too many organizations they
don't know the game they're in they talk
about being the best they talk about
being number one they talk about beating
their competition the problem is there's
no such thing let me give you a
real-life example that shed some light
on what I'm talking about
I spoke at an education summit at
Microsoft I also spoke at an education
summit at Apple at the Microsoft summit
the vast majority of the executives
spent the vast majority of their
presentations talking about how to beat
Apple at the Apple summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn one was
obsessed with where they were going
the other one was obsessed with their
competition guess which one was in
quagmire at the end of my talk at
Microsoft they gave me a gift they gave
me the new Zune when it was a thing
this was Microsoft's response to the
iPod and this little piece of technology
was absolutely incredible it was
beautifully designed the user interface
was intuitive and very simple to use it
was really brilliant I have to say so at
the end of my Apple talk I was sharing a
taxi with a very senior Apple executive
employee number 54 to be exact and I
decided to stir the pot I couldn't help
myself I turned to my said you know
Microsoft gave me their new Zune and it
is so much better than your iPod touch
to which he said I have no doubt then
the conversation was over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your competitor has the better
product and sometimes you have the
better product and sometimes you're
ahead and sometimes you're behind but
there's no such thing as best or first
or beating your competition
there's only ahead and behind and the
reality of an infinite game is you're
actually only competing against yourself
that the objective every single day is
how do we become a better version of our
own institution this year than we were
last year how do we improve the quality
of our culture how do we improve the
quality of the way we provide the
service that we claim to be providing
how do we improve ourselves that is the
main point of being an infinite game
because at the end of the day we don't
have the same metrics as everybody else
and we're not even necessarily playing
to the same ends the most important word
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you that sums
you Apple that would be like a little
beacon
[Music]
if you want more wisdom from Simon check
that first top 10 rules we did on him
the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want